hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday
monday morning podcast and i'm
just checking in on you
sorry i'm in a great mood because guess
what today i'm recording this the day
before thursday just before friday
monday morning
wednesday it's march 31st
and old billy freckles went a whole
[ __ ] month
into one [ __ ]
no weed no booze no cigars
no nothing no [ __ ] nothing
i did it good for me
so here's the deal oh and i also did
yoga this week
and i meditated what is happening
i am going to be if you guys think i was
obnoxious
when i was this angry toxic white cyst
whatever the [ __ ] whatever whatever
labels whatever box this the extreme
liberals
put someone like myself in because
they're so liberal they need to label
everybody
[ __ ] stupid [ __ ] um
i label them [ __ ] stupid [ __ ] um
yeah this is this is the crossroads all
right i went down to the crossroads this
is where i usually go well there i
proved to myself i could go 31 days
without doing
and then what is what does all freckles
do what does he do
after all is yeah yeah yeah [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] does he do
he goes right back and he [ __ ] he
calls from the [ __ ] house phone no
i go right back to [ __ ] drink it
or [ __ ] taking edibles or smoking
[ __ ]
20 cigars in a month um
i go back to it i go back to it and then
i just keep
and then i end up out of shape feeling
bad and [ __ ] hate myself again so i
was like okay so now i
what i need to do because i'm not done
with any of those things
i'm just trying to learn i got to get
myself in a headspace where i can do it
all these years of watching that
commercial you know drink responsibly
it's like what the [ __ ] are these
[ __ ] drink responsibly then why do
you sell them
24 at a time you think i got 23 other
friends that are coming over tonight
we're all gonna have one
responsibly speak it out on both sides
of your [ __ ] mouth but i i get it now
like today like once a week i go out
all right and i get myself a nice
italian sandwich
and uh i never have the time but i
always want to sit out front
and in a perfect world i could go out
there
and i could smoke a little cigar and
enjoy my little italian sandwich
you know just sit there right
feel the breeze shut it down
not think about [ __ ] don't look at my
phone right
once a week i figured you know i could
do something like that right but with
the cigar maybe i would
have the cigar once every couple of
months or something like that i would
love
to be that guy
that's the guy i want to be i just don't
know if i can do it because
um i got this thing where you know
i have a cigar and then i immediately
won another one
you know because i don't have anything
else that i do that's the [ __ ] thing
now
if i had like a drink and then i had a
cigar
now then i want another drink see i
can't [ __ ] do it
i'm not good at it i'm not good at it i
i
it this the switch is on or it's off i'm
not one of these people that has to go
to [ __ ]
all these weak people that have to go to
aaa and oh
this is my name and dude listen to my
[ __ ] store that was needy people
huh i swear to god i if i
if i was [ __ ] if i was running [ __ ]
if i was a dictator i would take
everybody in a
a and i'd take all the extreme liberals
and conservatives and i would stick them
all in the same boat
all right and that would be the only
reality show worth [ __ ] watching
um i'm [ __ ] with you i don't have any
problem with anybody in aaa i just
love making fun of people in aaa you
know
probably because i have some sort of i'm
on the spectrum
i don't know what it is i don't need a
sponsor i'm too [ __ ] anti-social for
a sponsor
hey bill just uh checking in to see how
you're doing
[ __ ] if you call me one more
time i'm gonna start drinking okay i
i get it i get it just talk to me in a
week i'll get my dumb chip
stop talking to me so um
i've never figured that out why i am a
loner that's another
one weird one i don't know it's a weird
thing but like i'm finally for the first
time you know how weird it is
to be yourself for over half a century
and now i've tried to figure out what
what the [ __ ] you are it's [ __ ] weird
man to turn the [ __ ]
the spotlight around and put it on
yourself and be like all right let's
let's stick this
under the [ __ ] magnifying glass see
what we got here oh
jesus i'm a [ __ ] mess i'll tell you
who wasn't a mess last night
were your boston bruins
what a [ __ ] game that was what a
gutsy
[ __ ] victory that was playing the new
jersey devils
great [ __ ] team this year them and
the islanders just [ __ ]
have owned the bruins and um
we still haven't beaten the islanders i
mean i don't know how we measure up
because my buddy was asking he goes dude
what do you think of the [ __ ] bruins
this year think we can make a run
it's like uh well i mean we haven't
beaten the islanders yet or the
you know the devils i think this is we
beat him the first game
we played him maybe um and it's been
nothing since then
and plus we're playing like what a
quarter of the league i don't know how
we match
up how do you gauge it i have no idea
but anyway
so we got down three to one
and evidently brad marchand decided that
he had [ __ ] seen enough
[ __ ] throws a check sends this guy on
his [ __ ] ass
and then drops the gloves and just
[ __ ] throw ragdolls this guy [ __ ]
ragdolled him
threw him to the [ __ ] ground the ice
right they gave him like two minutes for
[ __ ] roughing i don't know what they
gave him
he comes out of the box and then scores
a goal
and then it's three to two and like i'm
like here we go they're turning it
around
and then new jersey gives us the o right
there fred
right after we were still announcing the
[ __ ] goal i think and then they
scored
made it four to two and i'm like [ __ ]
man four to two
like historically the devils just once
they get once they're
winning they just know how to just shut
it down but i gotta tell you the defense
was uh
wasn't good in that game it was exciting
to watch i saw so many
you know at least we were giving up a
bunch of two on ones like odd man rushes
and everything
uh so it was kind of cool considering
how many odd man rushes we gave up
and so a couple of gift goals that went
off that face-off we won a face-off
and somehow just gave it right to the
the devils right right in front of the
net and they scored
a couple of gift goal one gift goal it
was great to see
um mcavoy and grizzlies got two goals in
the third period
one each uh to tie it up four four
and then pastrnak got the uh the
shootout
goal we finally won five to four
took us to like literally the last
player in the shootout i believe to uh
to beat the devils finally so
huge win very excited about that
um been having an awesome week here i
finally got my office i got all my
pictures up on the wall
and i realized how few pictures i have
of my friends
i got a great one of me and derosa we
had just done carnegie hall way back
like 10 years ago
almost 10 years ago i got one of me and
patrice
i don't know when that one's from that
one's from like the late 2000s
and then i got a i gotta i know i got
some of verzian bartnick
lawhead uh
there's gotta be something i gotta have
him somewhere around here then i gotta
get one of me and my wife i got a
classic one of me and my wife when we
first started dating on the red line
going into a red sox game
that one of my relatives took uh is in
black and white i gotta get that one
and get that one uh blown up put that
one on the wall
and um and then other than that
you know what the [ __ ] i did you know
what my dumbass did
this is like this is how like [ __ ]
like much i've slowed down my life here
which has really been a great thing i'm
literally living like the huey lewis hip
to be square thing right now
um which i know for younger people
you're like oh come on man
it gets sad it gets sad the older you
get when you keep living like that
so i am like i'm not saying don't go
have you fun go have go have your
[ __ ] fun for
god's sakes have a good time but like i
i had
my my good times so um
my daughter you know learned how to ride
the bicycle and now i taught her this
week
how to you know st i don't have to push
her off anymore she could just start the
bike herself and took her
a little bit a time to get used to that
but she's really good at balance
really understands it and is really sort
of one with her body man it's exciting
man like she's like
sort of has that athlete gene right so
um
she just started riding around the
driveway riding in circles and
everything and i was just like
all right i go i'm going to get on my
bike and i go here we go and actually
filmed it
our first bike ride together which what
and i'm telling you
she was just grinning ear to ear
um she was so proud of herself and my
mother-in-law was there her little
brother was there my wife was there i
was there we were all just
singing her praises and she was going
and going and going and going and then
she
wiped out really bad and i was like oh
no
and she immediately popped right up she
goes i'm okay i'm okay she was so
excited that she was getting pregnant
i'm okay so she goes uh
she goes i turned too fast or i turned
too sharp like she
just under she already understood what
she was doing so
i'm gonna go to the uh they got a
sporting goods store out here big five
i'm gonna buy some of those little
orange cones
i'm gonna take her out there's a parking
lot nearby and i'm just gonna set up
like a little
slalom thing that's gonna be fun for her
but also
getting her to uh
totally like master it so i don't have
to [ __ ] worry that she's gonna wipe
out again but uh
just having a great time doing that and
i'm so proud of her
so my big thing this week what i did for
myself was i ordered some [ __ ] for the
kitchen because i love cooking right
and i think one of the great inventions
of last century was the rubber spatula
i don't know you guys like me i [ __ ]
love a rubber spatula
it's just the things like so much stuff
always ends up having a sauce or
something like that and just nothing
gets it out of the bowl and into the pan
or out of the pan and onto your plate
like a [ __ ] rubber spatula
there's just the [ __ ] so i bought this
little three pack thing
and um because all we had we had the one
but it was
gigantic and it couldn't get into jars
and [ __ ] like that and it bothered me
so i bought these these you know small
one a medium-sized one and then one that
was like sort of regular sized with like
a scoop
i've been using the hell out of those
things and i've been making a bunch of
vegetarian [ __ ] so i've been cutting up
all these uh
vegetables and [ __ ] and uh you know
which takes a long [ __ ] time so i was
like all right you know what i'm gonna
get
i need to get one of those vegetable
slices that i see it's called a mandolin
which i thought was like a guitar used
in
like when whenever like zeppelin would
sing like their dungeons and dragon [ __ ]
like john paul jones would always break
out the mandolin right
but it's also a vegetable slicer so i
get this thing
it has all these attachments i did the
research i figured out i think i told
you guys i was so excited to get this
thing right
so i get it right and uh
you know i got some radishes and some
carrots so i just you know i read the
whole [ __ ] manual
which i never do and i just
i was like okay so i know what each one
of these even though i don't know what
julianne whatever cuts these are but i
just want to know what all of this [ __ ]
is
and i'm reading all of this [ __ ] and uh
you know so i cut up some radishes i cut
up the carrots squeezed some lemon on
them
it's [ __ ] delicious nice quick little
snack you know
gives you energy you're not going to be
a fat [ __ ] i'm loving this thing
but the radish has got all this red [ __ ]
on it and stuff so i i'm
rinsing it off in the uh in the sink and
then i just feel
in my [ __ ] finger really deep and i
ran in the thing
watch out the blade is super sharp oh my
god
you guys i got to tell you something man
i was just like
it was one of those one of those pain it
like just takes your breath away
i did it i just went like oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh no oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] ah
[ __ ] doing that thing so i grabbed a
paper towel
and i apply pressure right i'm doing all
this [ __ ] i learned you know stop drop
and roll keep it elevated all of this
[ __ ] you know
are you okay are you okay the choking
thing i'm trying every
first aid thing i know and i'm just
sitting there going
this does not that felt deeper than
something i'm gonna be able to put a
band-aid on
all right so i lift the paper towel
and at this point the part that i cut
was stuck to this is gross
was stuck to the paper towel and it
lifted up
like a toupee that wasn't glued on right
and i was like all right that needs
stitches that's good
so so i uh
i call up my wife
and she's awesome she takes me over to
urgent care
and uh i go over to urgent care and just
[ __ ] hilarious still like weighing me
and [ __ ] i'm like why do you need to
know this
well you've never been here before i'd
say well who says i'm coming back
you're already shut down my insurance
card now i gotta [ __ ] tell you how
much i weigh i don't know how much i
weigh
i'm [ __ ] cutting vegetable my fingers
bleeding because i don't like how much i
weigh i don't need you to [ __ ] tell
me this [ __ ]
so then i go in there and then how many
how many times a week do you work out
it's like how many [ __ ] times a week
do you work out
just suture up my [ __ ] finger
and let me get out of here right
so the nurse gets upset with me and i'm
like all right i'm being too much of a
dick so i answer questions i just say
listen i just don't like this [ __ ] cause
everybody [ __ ] ends up sharing the
information
she goes we don't share the information
i go you don't share the information
these people that run the hospital are
you gonna tell me that these are good
people and she's like
yeah yeah exactly
she's like how many times you work out a
week i'll make three and then i'm like
you know what this is gonna
[ __ ] with my insurance that doesn't pay
for anything it doesn't pay for anything
like a higher premium i said you know
what
say six and i go no five sounds more
believable she was a hot [ __ ] she put it
in
so she was great i was just in a uh
[ __ ]
i was disappointed in myself and then uh
the doctors came in
one doctor and then one of those
training and uh
yeah you got yourself pretty good they
were just telling me all they said they
got something over there they call it
avocado hand
and i go what's that he said well you
know people they cut an avocado in half
and then they want to get the seed out
and they take a nice whack at it with
the knife and they either
miss it completely or it glances off the
side
and then whacks down under their hand
and they got the mark of a squealer
on the palm of the hand and they got to
get that stitched up it's just like [ __ ]
i go i always do that and the dude was
just like don't ever do that i go i'm
never doing that again
so um
here's a question i have for people out
there
uh have you ever been stabbed
or have you ever been shot and have you
ever or have you ever had both of those
things happen to you
which one hurts more um
because i gotta tell you the uh there is
something
really creepy
about i know let's just just block your
ears if you're queasy
just slicing into your body
there's you know there's paper cuts
that's cutting yourself shaving
but then there's going deep enough where
it's just like
i cannot stop this bleeding
then there's that right um i was just
out of curiosity
because when you get shot it hurts so
bad you can't even feel it you just go
into shock
or you know or does it hurt even [ __ ]
more does it feel like that literally
you got hit by a cannon i have no
[ __ ] idea but
um yeah so that's what happened to me so
i got this [ __ ] mandolin now now i'm
afraid for anybody in the family to even
use it
but uh now now i'm good
um i think i'm gonna buy some of those
old lady like rubber gloves
when i wash it and then just rinse it
off and make sure i never go anywhere
near the blade and i have gloves on
because i don't want to i don't want to
uh do this again but um the doctors were
great they stitched me right up
and whatever [ __ ] um
whatever they used to numb me up with i
mean they stitch it up around
5 30 i was done and i woke up at two in
the morning
and my finger was still numb and then i
got nervous going oh [ __ ] did they put
the bandage on too tight and they cut
off the blood supply and my fingers die
and i started freaking out
so at like two in the morning i get up
with my big stupid fred flintstone
bandage on my finger
my finger and i go into the bathroom and
i took my nose hair clippers and i just
cut up the side
just to relieve it and then uh i went
back to bed
just to have it be a little more loose
right and then i went back to bed
at like you know whatever that probably
took me like five minutes to do that and
i woke up at like i think somewhere
between four and five
and my finger was killing me it was
throbbing and all that
and i actually smiled i was like okay
good good i didn't kill my finger
it's getting a bloody good it should
hurt it should hurt i [ __ ]
looked like i was cutting the cap off a
[ __ ] cigar
um so uh
anyway i'm sure you guys all have some
let's let's
i usually don't get into gross [ __ ] like
this but i'm sure people out there have
mandal oh my god i'm gonna look it up
right now mandolin
injuries do you dare here we go
mandolin
i'm probably not even spelling it right
injuries me john paul jones with a
broken nail
okay images images
oh whoa my
god oh my god she
oh my god yeah people oh
jesus
wow dude wow
wow i did all right
[ __ ] i did all right i just i
i went halfway i went halfway these
people cut their [ __ ] tips and their
fingers and thumbs off
jesus [ __ ] christ
oh my god i literally just closed my
[ __ ] laptop
um let's get into something a little
more nice less
less [ __ ] gross
shall we hang on a second let's uh
oh i did a for my first couple
instrument approaches
did a few more of those uh the other day
i did one into oxnard airport and i did
one into santa monica
wearing the foggles the second time
um having just a [ __ ] great time with
that all right
there we go okay let's see if i can find
this thing here
these guys wrote me a piece of music
hold on
all right this this song comes from
the guys from the band whiskey wolves of
the west
wrote me a theme song i don't know how
to do this here
for my podcast
you know we got low production value
here so it's nice you know
look at my old school dj i'm gonna talk
right until they start singing
here we go
[Music]
how great is that it goes on for a
[ __ ] while too like they really got a
whole goddamn song
so i gotta be able to i gotta post that
somewhere now i gotta i gotta promote
their album they came out with five
albums
i've had a chance to listen i'm so
[ __ ] busy i've just started listening
to this now that i got my uh
i got my uh my office all set up here
with my stereo
my [ __ ] hi-fi man uh
whiskey wolves of the west i found the
light
and uh according to them
there's five albums in here
it's an incredible
i mean amount of music i mean you know
you get into a pandemic you can be
somebody who just sort of [ __ ]
sits around right and does nothing or
you could just sit down and uh you know
write five albums of music uh tim jones
and
leroy powell are the brains behind this
let's see if we give anybody else a shot
i gotta give a shout out to the drummer
uh uh chris powell on drums
willie weeks on the base i mean come on
what a great name that is
it's a baseball name um
tom buckovac i hope i said that right
guitar
michael webb on the organ um
just what i've listened to so far i
[ __ ] love these albums
and uh i love that i got a great stereo
now
i might might upgrade the turntable i
have no [ __ ] idea but i'm i'm fixing
up my whole office i got this rotted out
wood on the threshold of the
right before the door you know you walk
in into the place i'm getting that fixed
and um and then downstairs my garage is
just totally just not [ __ ]
it's not lit up the way it needs to be
it's like too [ __ ] weak and i don't
know if you can just fix it with
higher wattage bulbs or whatever but it
just it's not lit up right so i need
i need some light down there i already
got the epoxy floor
it's gonna be my little [ __ ] area man
to chill out
you know man just you know meditate do
my yoga man
hey you guys got to let me know here
though
if if if i get too mellow and just stop
being funny
you know what i mean if i stop making
fun of the fatties
you just have to let me know all right
just please
please tell me you're going gonna do
that um all right let's let's read the
pot
uh the the advertising here oh look
everybody it's roman
you know most guys have tried different
ways to last longer
but thinking about baseball doesn't
always work
uh the i never understood that either
you know what i mean i'm [ __ ] banging
some broad and all of a sudden i started
thinking about mark maguire what am i
trying to do to myself
uh the folks at the folks at roman
an online men's health company are
changing the game
with roman swipes the secret to
longer-lasting sex
roman swipes are a clinically proven way
to last
longer in bed what the [ __ ] is this
where was this when i needed it um
they're effective easy to use and fast
acting
but don't require prescription
oh ladies be careful what you wish for
now you can have a [ __ ] porn star
you're gonna go from [ __ ] fast
freddie to [ __ ]
john holmes uh roman can stop can oh
sorry roman can ship
swipes how do they work to you
in a discreet unmarked package and each
swipe's packet is small enough to hide
in your wallet
for whenever you need it oh my god
that's hilarious
so if you're like a minute man and
you're gonna bang some broad you've
never met before you go hang on a second
you know go to the bathroom little swipe
swipe swipes then you come up
all right coming out like tyson walk
into the [ __ ] ring
probably a bad reference uh wipe swipes
are great
they will not transfer to your partner
so you can last
longer without worrying they're super
easy to use
just take the swipes out of the packet
swipe it on
let it dry and you're good to go that's
it
what does it do go to get roman.com
burr dude i don't give a [ __ ] any guy
who's busting it too quick doesn't give
a [ __ ] what it does
slap that on me like a turtleneck get
roman g-e-t-r-o-m-a-n.com
and get ten dollars off your first order
of swipes plus free
two-day shipping that's getroman.com for
ten dollars off your first order
of swipes and free two-day shipping
all right now i'm curious i got to see
what what do roman
swipes do what do they do what do they
do
roman swipes congratulations to the ucla
bruins knocking off my michigan
wolverines i love both of those programs
um i'm gonna be one of those guys late
to the party i'm just gonna watch the
final four from what i heard
is the um the um
gonzaga who i was making fun of like ah
they're undefeated they played in the
[ __ ] whack who the hell are they
playing huh [ __ ]
[ __ ] montana state community college
uh i guess they're unbelievable to watch
um playing a team game paul vergie's
been just going off on them telling me
how [ __ ] great they are so
i gotta check it out all right how does
how do how to swipe roman swipes work
roman makes it simple to get real
medication
why won't you say what it does
does it numb your dick
does it feel like my finger at two in
the morning what's going on here
how does it work by
benzocaine roman swipes are topical
anesthetic
that reduce the intensity of sexual
stimulation and
prolong it the duration of sex
without completely removing the sexual
oh my god
that's hilarious [ __ ] dip your balls
in ice
oh god that's [ __ ] hilarious um
at 5 00 pm i thought i was doing this at
three oh god
i what point am i ever gonna write
anything down sorry i just got a text
all right what did i say
is it five p in his time
hang on a second sorry everybody i i
blew i missed didn't blow it off i
[ __ ] missed it yesterday 3 p.m
my time though ah jesus or
5 p.m east coast time
no pacific coast there we go sorry
sorry to listen to that [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right
here we go anyways plowing ahead here um
you know what i was psyched about i was
watching i
was like flipping through uh and i
stopped on the mlb channel
major league baseball and uh this guy
was talking some nice singing a lot of
nice things about the red sox lineup
this year uh i'd say it's xander
bogart's team now he's the he's the
i can't believe it now he's the old man
on the team um but i guess they think we
got a lot of firepower in the lineup i
don't know what
um i'm excited but i am [ __ ] really
excited for baseball
this year um probably because i'm gonna
be in town
um yeah so it was right 3pm my time all
right i gotta wrap this [ __ ] podcast
up to go
do the podcast yesterday i forgot to
[ __ ] do because i was out flying
around like a [ __ ] chopper boy there
um all right that's it everybody if you
can't last long what you wanna do is
slightly numb your dick
that's what you do here's another thing
too you gotta own that
you got to own that just say that where
are you going i gotta i'm gonna put a
listen
your [ __ ] is so amazing i need a
topical anesthetic on my dick i mean
that's gotta be that's gotta be an ego
boost for a woman you know you gotta
numb your dick up even you [ __ ] walk
near
me what the [ __ ] i'm bringing to the
table
um all right that's the podcast
everybody just checking in on you quick
little [ __ ] half hour there
um i don't know what else to tell you
have a great weekend you [ __ ]
uh good luck to ucla baylor
gonzaga and houston those are the four
teams left i don't know who's playing
who
but um i'll be checking out i'll be
checking that out
uh this weekend i promise you all right
go bro let's go celtics go red sox go
[ __ ] your shows
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
april 1st 2013
that's right everybody it's april fool's
day holy [ __ ]
is is this podcast going to be wacky
is he going to pull a prank is he
pranking us right now
is that his voice i would tell you guys
how much i [ __ ] hate this day
you know what i mean back when i was in
the matrix
and i actually had a day job and i was a
productive member of society
you know and i actually used to sit
there and i'd go to [ __ ] work every
goddamn day
and every once in a while at the end of
the day
they'd say some [ __ ] like uh you know
we'd uh appreciate
it it's uh not mandatory but we would
appreciate it if uh you guys could hang
around for a couple minutes
after five today we'd like to talk about
uh some of our
productivity goals in the upcoming
quarter
and i would actually hang out going i
got to do this i i gotta
i gotta i gotta put on i uh i gotta put
on uh you know
i gotta be a team player here and i
would sit there and listen to these
[ __ ] suits
you know talking about uh you know
unloading trucks or whatever the [ __ ]
they were talking about and oh that is
interesting oh that's great oh oh are we
gonna upgrade to the electronic [ __ ]
pallet jacks
pallet jacks haven't said pallet jack in
like [ __ ] 25 years
we were all excited wow they really give
a [ __ ] about us
now they don't they're just worried
they're going to get sued because the
[ __ ] coke had just blew out his
goddamn back
you know and then they're like what if
everybody blows out their backs
how do we avoid that what is going to be
cheaper
paying their workman's comp or actually
getting them the proper equipment
um so anyways the stupid [ __ ] april
fool's jokes right
i used to hate those [ __ ] goddamned
you know what i hated about it was
half the people who would get you they
weren't funny
and they they they're this is their idea
you know be like
they'd be like uh you be like hey do you
know where the pens are yeah they're in
they're right in that drawer and then
you open they're like april fool
yeah they're not in that drawer they're
actually in this one over here i just
got him
i got him with an april fool
you know and you wonder why offices get
shot up
you know that's what it is it's not
because of sociopaths it's not because
of
um um relaxed gun control laws
it's not because of any of that [ __ ]
it's because of some stupid april fool's
joke that someone won't let go and
they're talking [ __ ] about it
still in june you know and then somebody
just finally snaps and they come in
there and they mow down a bunch of
people
and it's considered a tragedy and it is
unless
you're into the environment
and you look at it a different way and
you're like well you know as tragic
as everything that just happened is
there's going to be a whole lot
a whole lot less people dropping deuces
in that building
that will end up in the water supply
do you know i went to the grocery store
the other day people oh yeah
i'm not a vampire i need food
and i [ __ ] walk i'm walking in there
and there's some
[ __ ] greenpeace guy with a clipboard
and he's singing like r and b [ __ ]
and i didn't want to hit him i just had
to get away from him
like it was literally affecting how i
was walking he was just singing
he was i don't know what like he was
trying to audition
and save the environment all at the same
[ __ ] time he was singing some song
and at one point he went like whoa
doing that [ __ ] that r b
you know let me hold this note like i'm
getting tickled
i'm sorry folks i did a benefit in a
[ __ ] mind this weekend and i'm a
little [ __ ]
i'm a little i'm a little ugh
i feel like [ __ ] [ __ ] people i caught
one of these uh one of these super cults
did you guys have it did you get a
chance to listen to me last week
on um the joe rogan experience
i might have mentioned that i was
starting to get sick that was the day
when i did joe rogan's podcast and i
forgot that the guy does an 18-hour
podcast
you know i'm thinking like all right
i'll go over there i'll be done in about
90 minutes
i'll come back here get myself a little
bit of robitussin
chase it with a little bit of nyquil do
a line of blow
you know [ __ ] stare down the cold
wide awake and then that'll be it and no
that's not what happened i did a three
and a half hour podcast with rogan you
know what's amazing about doing rogan's
podcast it's three and a half [ __ ]
hours long
and it feels like 20 minutes you know
until you get to the last 20 minutes so
you're just like dude i i can't [ __ ]
talk anymore
and the amazing thing about rogan is if
i think if you didn't bring it up
that you were three and a half hours in
he would do another three and a half
hours
um but i had a great time on that one
and um
i sounded extra dumb on that because
rogan actually reads
you know i sound dumb enough when i'm
just by myself but when i'm actually on
a podcast where there's somebody who's
actually a well-read guy
you know my level of stupidity really
gets [ __ ] exposed
to an even higher level so um
anyways yeah i've been sick for like
four [ __ ] days i didn't actually
didn't take any and i didn't take any
cold medicine because every [ __ ] cold
medicine i looked at said may do
permanent liver damage
so i was like all right well let's do
the math here i either go
[ __ ] two three days of hell
and then i'm fine or i
i i [ __ ] [ __ ] out of three days of
hell
and the trade-off is permanent [ __ ]
liver damage right how [ __ ] dumb
would that be
you know if you take cold medicine
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] it's basically
what i'm saying
no that's not true that's not true
because you know what i don't have to
[ __ ] go to work
you guys do and how many sick days can
you really use
especially if you're a woman you know
if you get knocked up and you're already
you how many days do they give you for
that
it's so [ __ ] pathetic in this country
that like
you ever see i i don't know other
countries like how much time you get off
and then people like yeah but they pay
like [ __ ] you know 9
90 taxes in that country
yes so what at least they get something
for their [ __ ] taxes what the [ __ ]
are we getting in this country
oh i got my 2x4 out i'm the angry voter
everybody
um despite the fact that i was as sick
as i was i was sick as a dog man
i uh
i still got the windows tinted on my car
i got a couple of things done you know
what's funny was uh
the lovely beautiful and talented nia
was actually leaving town on wednesday
and came back yesterday and i got sick
literally tuesday night and i was sick
the whole [ __ ] time
i was so [ __ ] excited
that you know not like excited she was
gonna be leaving i was just excited that
you know
she wasn't gonna be here
you know much madness gonna watch the
[ __ ] basketball
have the fellas over right [ __ ]
barbecue
drink some beers right i was gonna have
a great time
a great [ __ ] time and then i i got
this goddamn tsunami of a [ __ ] cold
and uh dude it really wiped me out
two days i was just laying on the couch
just going really are you [ __ ]
this is a cold this is this is what a
cold is in 2013.
dude my [ __ ] hair hurt i thought it's
because i was dehydrated just started
sucking down water and all i did was
make me gag
you know it hurt to move my eyes
i can't move my eyes man um
it was it was [ __ ] brutal so
i toughed it out and i still got i got
the windows tinted on my car
and uh that was hilarious i went down
there i went to this [ __ ]
place where it's like do you guys like
tint windows and also torture people in
the back room
you know one of those really shady
places i didn't go down on the
dealership because i knew they were
going to charge me my [ __ ] 500 bucks
to have the official toyota tint put on
the windows i'm like [ __ ] this let me
just get this guy to do it for a buck
and a quarter
um so i go in there right and then
obviously english is a second language
for this guy
you know and uh
i'm sure i could have had my pick of
women too if i actually went into that
back room
it just seemed like one of those things
i just felt like i was in the second
season of the wire
you know like there was going to be some
big cargo tin with a bunch of dead
hookers in it in the back
but anyways that's none of my business
i'm just here to get my windows tinted
on my [ __ ] hybrid
so uh i say to the guy like all right i
want the back windows as dark as i can
possibly get him because my dog rides
back there
and she's always panting to beat the
[ __ ] band i'd like her to be cooler
and then up front
you know the darkest i can get and then
i was like wait a minute wait a minute i
go you know my girl kind of stinks at
driving so
i don't want it so dark that she can't
see other cars and he laughs
you know this [ __ ] eastern european
black market [ __ ] laugh and uh he
goes all right we'll do the 35 percent
and then we'll do the uv
rays up front and i'm like great so
yeah you got a guy he does them enough
they they look [ __ ] phenomenal
so i'm recovering the next [ __ ] two
more days of this [ __ ]
all right i finally come around
yesterday and uh
i'm feeling good and i know nia's on her
way home so what do i do
i [ __ ] clean up the goddamn house
that's a big thing you have to do when
your [ __ ] woman leaves town
when she comes back the place has to
look
even [ __ ] better it has to look
[ __ ] great
and there's got to be food in the fridge
okay
why because out of respect no
out of love no then why would you do it
bill i'll tell you why
because you can't [ __ ]
you can't give them that [ __ ] power
that they feel like
you're an absolute [ __ ] [ __ ]
if they're not there you know they start
feeling that after a while because you
know
when you [ __ ] live with somebody like
a woman they basically decide where
everything goes that's like
[ __ ] that you both use and you're a guy
and you don't give a [ __ ]
right so every [ __ ] time you gotta be
like yeah where's the salad spoon where
the [ __ ] is this where the [ __ ]
is that and then they get to be like the
[ __ ] chick on on a sitcom right well
my husband he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] right
so i didn't want to have her that i
didn't want her to have that [ __ ]
victory
i vacuumed i did everything took the
trash out i had everything just looking
[ __ ] spotless
you're gonna come home looking at me
like i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
well honey the place looks great yeah i
met you when i was 36.
i know how to make toast all right
get over yourself
i was actually cleaning up so well it
was like she's gonna think i cheated on
her or something this is like
this is getting [ __ ] ridiculous
what'd you vacuum for you getting rid of
the [ __ ] straight pube hairs there
um this is the monday morning podcast
everybody
um now that would have been that would
have said if i actually cheated on it
what a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
first of all and then second of all like
um
i would have a sex addiction if i
actually did that because of how [ __ ]
sick
sick i was you know
if i actually banged one of those
[ __ ] eastern european [ __ ] that i
know were
locked in the back of that tinted out
[ __ ] place
um you know what's funny was we she gets
home
all right and we and within within an
hour we
were in a fight because i told the story
about getting the windows
tinted like an [ __ ] i wasn't even
thinking and i mentioned to the fact
that i said she wasn't the greatest
driver
and i heard her feelings you said that
you don't think i'm a good driver
oh jesus christ and that's one of those
ones where you just gotta be like okay
ah bill you're an idiot why did you say
that you know
i'm still pissed that she got pissed
about that
you know that would be like if she told
one of her friends that i'm not a good
dancer and then i was like you told her
i'm not a good dad what the f
yeah bill you suck you suck at dancing
you know jesus [ __ ] christ
i don't [ __ ] kills me about [ __ ]
women it's like they they even when they
know they stink at something
if you say they stink at something they
get they get all [ __ ] offended
you said the truth why why why would you
say what's actually happening you know
i'm a terrible [ __ ] dancer i think
maybe i could in another life i could
have been a good dancer but all like
like happy emotions were beaten out of
me by the time i was [ __ ] four years
old so you know
just dancing i mean i can't i don't it's
just it's not even in me
that whole [ __ ] whatever that gift is
whenever that is whatever
that the dancing dust is [ __ ]
sprinkled on you that was not sprinkled
on me in any way
shape or [ __ ] form you know
even the music i like this isn't the
angry music
except for bruno mars every once in a
while i got i got a little
again that's not true wait a minute bill
come on
who else you got in there night ranger
um hey did you see these [ __ ] uh
these guys want to blow us
up now you know before i get into that
how about a little advertising everybody
let's let's do something e-voice
everybody
they're back they're back on the podcast
e-voice is the reason you're gonna make
money in 2013
let me repeat that e-voice
is the reason you're gonna make money in
2013. hey
why are you gonna make money in 2013
because of e-voice
when your customers call you'll have
your own toll-free number
professional greeting dial by name
directory and more
oh this is basically if you want to
start your own business and you want to
make it seem
like you actually own your own
skyscraper but you actually you know
are still living in your parents attic
e-voice is the way to go to make
yourself sound
unbelievably professional you'll sound
like a fortune 500 company and you'll
blow away your competitors
simply by sounding that professional
that's what it all is people
it's not about your product it's about
what it sounds like when they call your
company
all right e-voice lets you give out one
number that rings wherever you are
the beach the bar doesn't matter you'll
sound like you're at your office
you gotta go to evoice.com and use a pro
use promo code bill
e-voice even takes all your voicemails
transcribes them and sends them
instantly
as a text or email uh email that's great
so then you can be at your other job
you know you don't have to be on the
phone you can act like you're typing as
you sit there looking at your
uh your your uh your voicemails so you
can check
uh voicemails before the meeting ends
and not look rude
evoice is only 10 bucks a month but
right now listeners to my podcast can
try evoice for
free for six months
that's right a six month free trial
support my podcast stop what you are
doing hit pause set up your e-voice free
trial
and see what i'm talking about go to
evoice.com and use promo code bill
that's evoice.com promo code bill one
more time
evoice dot com promo code bill
i don't like how they slip that in there
stop do what you're doing and hit pause
see what they just did there oh that was
kind of sneaky
my dumb ass reddit um
anyways you see these north korean [ __ ]
are allegedly going to try and blow us
up
this is [ __ ] amazing they got this
video
it's [ __ ] ah jesus christ bill d can
you can you just have anything ready to
go
this is why am i eventually actually
gonna have like a whole
no i'm not gonna do that actually have
like a like an official radio setup
you know i'm not gonna do that because
then you know what then i happen this
somewhere i have to be
there's people i have to answer to and
all that [ __ ] horse [ __ ] i'm not
doing it
i was watching this whole thing on um
uh north korea
and how they made they made this promo
video
and it's basically about them launching
their own space shuttle it's this north
korean dude i'm assuming
right and he's sitting there dreaming
and they have the instrumental of we are
the world
in the background right we are the world
we are the children this [ __ ]
north korean space shuttle is flying
around
you know flying around the globe korea
is unified and um
you know it ends with a city that looks
like new york
which is on fire after some sort of
missile attack
you know but i guess they say and it
looks like the evil doers did themselves
in
they don't take responsibility for doing
it but i guess
you know i don't know evidently that was
cause for big concern
not in my world though even though la i
guess is one of the main
first ones they want to attack i don't
give a [ __ ]
is that going to make you happy there
[ __ ]
whole [ __ ] fat face there fat face
part two
you know i can see why we're annoying
i mean we got in the middle of their
fight over there way back in the day
we should have minded our own business
let him duke it out
whoever wins wins but we didn't we stuck
our [ __ ] noses in over there
and now they don't like us what would we
do
during the [ __ ] uh civil war if all
of a sudden uh
korea came over here was like hey hey we
side with these guys
other side why don't you settle down
after a while be like hey why don't you
guys get the [ __ ] out of here
let us solve our own [ __ ] problems i
get it
you know i just don't understand
what north korea has what their
fascination is with having a fat
dictator
they like a real pudgy [ __ ] uh
like on medication like bloated face
kind of [ __ ] dictator that's that
thing
i don't i'm not worried about it i would
be more worried if they were gonna try
and blow up san francisco
because i'm in los angeles okay if
you're gonna [ __ ] shoot a goddamn
nuclear weapon at this country by all
means
do it at the city that i'm in because i
don't want to survive it
all right that's where you want to be by
the way
all these [ __ ] people trying to come
up with these underground places to go
that's not where you want to be
you want to be right where the [ __ ]
cone of that missile hits
that's where you want to be just get
vaporized you have no idea you don't
even know what's coming
sitting there watching sports in it
it's it over you know you don't want to
be on the outskirts
like in scottsdale [ __ ] arizona
with one side of your [ __ ] face
melted off and then walking around for
four days
looking for wheat thins you want to do
that
you have some [ __ ] agonizing like
18-day death [ __ ] that
i want to be vaporized you know
like you ever see a bunch of bugs and
you hit him with some raid that [ __ ]
one that takes the direct hit that thing
is done in two seconds
but the other ones are doing that little
[ __ ] angus young
running on the ground during a guitar
solo [ __ ] move those are the ones you
don't want to be
right
i don't know i don't give a [ __ ] about
north korea i'm not worried about those
guys
all right you want to [ __ ] start some
[ __ ] go ahead
all right start some [ __ ] [ __ ]
what are they gonna do
like what what exactly is that that
their [ __ ] game plan
you're gonna did it's not so like not
even a throw okay you're gonna what
you're gonna take out two cities
we have enough [ __ ] to [ __ ] blow up
the entire world like nine million
times so you're gonna take out los
angeles
right and then then you know what you're
not gonna have any movies to watch
you ever think about that north korea
god knows your dad loved watching all
our [ __ ] movies you're gonna have
none of that [ __ ]
right you're gonna have half the [ __ ]
divas that you're gonna
that you're gonna hire to perform at
your [ __ ] new year's party like
beyonce
they're not gonna be there isn't beyonce
one of the ones that perform for some
[ __ ] mass murdering psychopath
was it her i don't [ __ ] know i'll
throw her name out you know i'll take
her name off
and i'll say it was uh uh boo's face
there
from the voice the one who likes to get
dirty
what's her name christina applegate
aguilera there you go
was it her she's another one she does
that r
b singing [ __ ] pointing everywhere
[ __ ] voices going
seems like she's sitting on a giant
vibrator
um jesus said [ __ ] it
if you notice that with her she just
said to hell with it i don't give a [ __ ]
you know i'm just gonna be almost in
shape
and you guys can just [ __ ] deal i had
a kid i like having a glass of wine
around four in the afternoon go [ __ ]
yourself i'm i like i really respect
that
she doesn't care you know like if she
was a dude
she'd be one of those guys who couldn't
wear a tie because it
it's just [ __ ] she can't breathe at
that point
she would she dressed like dana white um
all right i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about here
if you guys see that they're gonna have
these new smell-o-visions
real smell-o-vision tv unveiled by
japanese team
and it's not an april fool is what it
says a tokyo team
invent a smelling screen that makes
smells
emanate from the spot on the screen
showing their corresponding object
it works by feeding odors from
sublimating gel pallets
or pellets into air streams
and did i say is it's sublimating
that doesn't sound right like i don't
think i pronounced that correctly
whatever gel
pellets into air streams that can be
directed to specific spots on the screen
so what are you going to have like a
bunch of pellets
for every sta that just it's not going
to work you know what the sad thing
about this stupid [ __ ] thing is
it says that the development promises to
make advertisement for fried
chicken or fresh coffee even more
appealing you know who's gonna get this
[ __ ] thing i swear to god
bobby kelly dude i got the new
smell-o-vision jim
dude i'm watching the food network i was
[ __ ] drooling dude
the guy's making a [ __ ] lobster
souffle
i could [ __ ] smell the [ __ ] beach
dude
you know and he'll buy it right when it
comes out so he can be the first guy in
his blog to have it
it'll cost him 15 grand and then in like
[ __ ] four years they're going to be
selling for like 600 bucks
that's that's the one of the things
about being at the forefront of
technology when you just have to be the
first
douchebag on your block you know
i got i have to have him on this podcast
because i really i really want to talk
to him about that
like what what is that because i see it
it like it like fills him up
when i used to be in new york city and
he would get some new gadget
he couldn't [ __ ] wait to come down to
the cellar
and think of some phony reason to pull
out his new shiny thing
just dying for someone to be like oh is
that the new [ __ ]
shiny [ __ ] fousey 1000
and then he that then he'd be like oh oh
why
yes yes it is dude check it
it charges my iphone boom you open this
over here
flap i got all my dates zowie
that [ __ ] has had everything
[ __ ] everything i like
15 years ago when he still had his
noodle hair he [ __ ] had
anything that had a stylist that pom-pom
he had
everything he had that i lived with him
he had that and he had bags
those are the two things that he was
[ __ ] into
and you know what i was into eating
bland food and staring at the wall
so who [ __ ] won who won in that one i
would say bobby
um all right let's get to some [ __ ]
uh some goddamn questions for this
[ __ ] week here
uh by the way i don't know if i brought
this up yet because i've had to start
this podcast a couple times because i
had a coughing fit
uh um obviously
the fastest most speediest recovery
possible for uh kevin ware of the uh
of louisville jesus christ that was one
of the that's one of the worst
things i've ever seen and um
and if you haven't seen it you know what
just it's killing me is i know there's
going to be a bunch of people who upload
that [ __ ] video
and then douche bags will have to make
jokes and that type of thing but what a
tough [ __ ]
this guy basically he broke i don't know
if it was a compound fracture if it was
if it was
both bones or whatever but i know at
least one of them
you know was coming through the [ __ ]
skin
and he's still laying there telling
everybody to win the [ __ ] game
jesus christ that wouldn't have been me
i would have been crying like a [ __ ]
girl and saying you know
games i would have used up all our
timeouts
[Laughter]
and i could give a [ __ ] about the game
at that point i would be screaming i
would have been like
nancy kerrigan why why
[Music]
why
[Laughter]
oh that's one of my favorite clips of
all time because you know what i love
i love that she acted exactly how i
would have acted
everybody wants to act like they're
going to be the hey win one for the
gipper
and you know what most of us got that
nancy kerrigan gene
you know and we're just going to start
crying and be like why me
um
that really was that was right up there
as far as like
you know she'd obviously never gotten
her ass kicked in her life
it's the fact that she couldn't even
wrap her [ __ ] head around
you know if she had gotten her ass
kicked a couple of times she at least
would
she why me would have been downgraded to
dude what the [ __ ]
oh my god what the [ __ ] like
why why
um i don't even know where the [ __ ] i
was going with that
i'm sorry guys this [ __ ] podcast
sucks this week i i'm i'm
all right i admit it it sucks this week
i'm [ __ ] i'm still sick
but you know yesterday's was flat
yesterday's [ __ ] last weeks was a
great one okay so give me a little bit
of slack here cut me a little slave for
crazy can you do that
um all right oh by the way you know
something uh
a couple weeks ago i mentioned the fact
that um
i don't get the you know the premier
league as far as their their soccer over
there where
their jerseys can be just so the colors
are so
uh dramatically different like you'll be
watching a team and they're red and
white and then next week they're wearing
black and yellow and it's like what the
[ __ ]
and uh this guy wrote and he said uh in
the premier league colors change
uh for example
arsenal play man united they both wear
red and white so the away team changes
colors
that's why they change the team because
i guess
and it's kind of weird that they're in
the same league and guys can have the
same colors
you know which is starting to happen in
american sports
like however the toronto maple leafs
sued the tampa bay lightning for their
new [ __ ] jerseys yet
you know they're slowly moving in on
your [ __ ] territory and i don't know
why you're not saying anything
um all right anyways bill
your workout routine hey bill unlike 95
of americans on your shows you look like
what i think most people would look like
should look like in terms of fitness
uh you see what he did there he gave me
a nice big compliment as he [ __ ]
trashed 95 percent of america it's not
95 percent it's a good
[ __ ] 65 americans
um do you follow a specific routine
thanks um
well right now i'm in [ __ ] horrible
shape i put on [ __ ] 10 pounds but
this is the thing i never let it get
beyond this
you know my i never let it get beyond
like a little bit of [ __ ]
like 10 pounds and then i just take it
off that's basically what i do
i hike with my dog and uh
and i i use my own body weight
i use my own body weight because i find
that that that makes you more
cut rather than puffy if you [ __ ]
lift weights and [ __ ]
you get you just start over developing
like five different groups of muscles
and uh you start walking around looking
like a [ __ ] bouncer at least i do
so i you a climbing rope i have a
pegboard
and i have uh a pull-up and dip station
uh because i i am a firm believer that
you need to be able to move your own
body
you know and i used to do yoga [ __ ]
years and years ago but um
i don't know i just can't get myself to
go to the classes those [ __ ] mats are
all dirty and [ __ ]
even if you bring your own mat it's just
the level of sweating and bare feet
is just [ __ ] disgusting and uh
you know and then also the chicks in
there so [ __ ]
ridiculous looking that at least out
here in l.a
um you know the whole mental aspect of
the thing is out the [ __ ] window
because you're supposed to be like you
know also calming your mind
and i'm not calming my mind my mind is
[ __ ] going
[Laughter]
so um yeah that's what it is
and i try not to eat like an [ __ ] and
now that i'm of advanced age gonna be 45
years old i try to eat a [ __ ] giant
salad every day
and uh is while fighting that what are
you a [ __ ] [ __ ] voice in my head
but um as much as people sit there and
they say that that's bird food and that
type of thing eat a giant salad every
day and i'm telling you
yeah you're going to be right as rain
all right
i'm telling you if you don't eat a salad
every day and you're eating [ __ ] a
bunch of meat and that type of thing
i swear to god trying to take a [ __ ] is
is like [ __ ] it's not a fun
experience
you have a giant salad every day it's
not a problem
that's you know what that was true but
disgusting but i don't give a [ __ ]
there you go so that's what i do um all
right
cooking billy boyardee
what are some of your favorite things to
cook in the kitchen
i was never much of a cook until i
realized it's super easy
um well you must have a gift then what
do you mean super easy what are you
making
eggs over easy yeah that's easy but i
mean you're actually you know doing some
of that food network stuff i don't think
it's super easy
second you gotta have like a an ice bath
bath to like blanch some [ __ ]
you know anyways uh
or caramelizing [ __ ] you just gotta
experiment and think the basics through
the food network mentioned a website
called myfridgefood.com that tells you
what you can make with the ingredients
in your house i accidentally learned how
to make teriyaki sauce
and pumpkin pie because of what i've had
what i had in my place that's actually
interesting
you mentioned once you made ribs have
you mastered anything
what's your go to um
if i mastered anything uh
the [ __ ] can i do uh i don't know i
don't know i i'm one of those people
every once once every eight months i
throw down and i cook and i make a
[ __ ] great meal
um i'll make you a spaghetti sauce if
you like a sweeter one that has some
molasses in it
and it will literally make you punch
your [ __ ] wife in the face
repeatedly just [ __ ] just drawn back
with each chew just you are as you bite
down
you let the [ __ ] you letting your hands
go you know
you're free that's how good this
spaghetti sauce is i can make you a
lasagna
meat based of course um to do i can do
all of that [ __ ]
i can make you some [ __ ] short ribs
there yeah i can [ __ ] cook if i gave
a [ __ ]
if i really wanted to i could get really
good at cooking i'm actually
i'm really good at baking i think i tell
a nice story
i don't like this [ __ ] i don't like
being i don't like these two [ __ ]
questions here where i'm talking
positively about myself you know why
because there's absolutely no humor in
it all right let's get back to the
[ __ ] grip strength you know why you
need
grip strength in case you're ever in a
[ __ ] house fire
and you need to climb down the goddamn
gutters or you need to go up to the roof
and then take a run and leap to the
house next to it and you're gonna come
up
short and you're gonna [ __ ] grab
something over there or maybe a [ __ ]
tree branch
that's what you need grip strength for
all right
i guess if you lift weights and you ever
get sucked into a sinkhole you can
[ __ ] lift your house off of you i
don't know what
all right as far as cooking yeah i don't
think cooking said uh
cooking the whole thing is you got to
have all these you know if you really
want to throw down
it's that initial startup cost it's like
when you first learn how to fix a car
it's not going to be cheaper than taking
it to somewhere else because you're
going to have to [ __ ] not only buy
the parts you can have to buy all the
tools
um so
i don't know have i mastered anything
yeah i can make a [ __ ] pie
i can make cakes i could bake i can
grill i i'm not the greatest griller i
gotta admit i i get very impatient with
grilling
i know i'm supposed to have like the
caveman [ __ ] and want to be standing out
there over the [ __ ] fire i'm really
not uh
into that i used to work in a restaurant
and i worked a mesquite grill
and i had the big [ __ ] chef hat and
all that type of [ __ ] and i made great
burgers and shrimp brochettes and
chicken sandwiches and that [ __ ] i know
how to do it
i can mock up the meat i can [ __ ]
cook i just don't i'm just
i have to be into it and i get into it
i'm psycho into it for like three weeks
and then i'm just not i don't give a
[ __ ] after a while
um because i have [ __ ] a dd
you know basically stand-up comedy is
the only thing i ever stuck with so
hence it's the only thing i'm ever i'm
really good at i can play drums okay i
can play a little guitar
i can make a couple of dishes and uh
i can shoot the [ __ ] about the weather
at a party and then pretty much that
other than that i'm done
um underrated the bible
the bible all right uh
oh jesus here we go at the risk of
pissing you off i'm running to say that
the bible is underrated
that doesn't piss me off i mean it's a
hell of a story
you know uh really all religious texts
are underrated
and i can't blame anyone for underrating
religion since religion
is a lot of uh speculative crap
um no i think the basis of all religions
are the way you should live life like
the ten commandments
is like common sense the seven deadly
sins i love that [ __ ]
it's that it's that once you start being
like you know he he loves us best
and you don't believe what we're saying
so uh your infidels and now we have to
kill you
or we have to have a crusade or we have
to torture you
until you're into what the [ __ ] we're
into
or we're making so much money off this
horseshit we have to look the other way
while some of us are [ __ ] children
you know
that that's where i i i make my
departure
you know or you're constantly telling me
that this
thing is [ __ ] mad at me because i'm
flawed
despite that's the way he [ __ ] made
me like that's never made sense to me
um or like
if there's a god that you know he makes
somebody like a sociopath
and sociopath is basically a broken
human being
like they didn't get all the parts and
it's like not even it's like not even
their fault that that
that they're born that way that
they don't feel anything all right
that's not that that person's going to
hell because they were born
[ __ ] up you know
now i'm not saying i have sympathy for
sociopaths i think they should be
hunting down and [ __ ] shot in the
street like rabid dogs
but i'm just saying as far as the uh are
you going to heaven to hell
i mean isn't that like on on the
manufacturer
i've always equated it to that like you
know
it'd be like if you built built a piece
of [ __ ] car like you [ __ ] up
you [ __ ] it up when you built it and
then you get mad at it because it
doesn't run right
you know so that that's my thing so you
know if you're into the bible i don't
give a [ __ ]
um anyway i want to bring up up the book
of job
huh look at that i said it right i
didn't say job
job which reads as a tale of cruelty
because god and the devil got together
to put job through the ringer
do you know how bad i would love to read
the book of job and actually be able to
read more than two paragraphs without
sitting there going what the [ __ ] are
they talking about
um i think most people religious and
otherwise miss an important point
throughout the text job's friends went
half cocked saying that job must have
must have done
something to deserve what was happening
to him
sounds like the type of thing a lady
would say
not me that sounds a type of thing like
a religious nut would say to me
at the end god became angry with job's
friends for making this assumption
and made them do sacrifices just for
being smart ass [ __ ]
um so the bible has all kinds of moral
concepts
that have barely survived into the
modern era probably thanks to all the
linguistic
mangling well thank god you're there to
figure it all out
job demonstrates that the burden of
proof falls upon the accuser
it's even part of our justice system but
nobody gives it
the importance it deserves especially
christians
if there's a god he definitely pissed
he's definitely pissed at you know who
no i don't i don't know who
i was totally with you until you put it
all on the christians but now i think
that
which means you're either jewish or
muslim or [ __ ]
i don't know what is there something
else
who are those people who pray to the
trees
hippies is that a religion
huh dirty hippies
that's not a religion hindu
no not hindu hari krishna
aren't harry christians just dirty
hippies who shave their heads
or am i thinking of that charles manson
movie where the manson family all shaved
their heads
i don't [ __ ] know i don't know what
your point was sir
it made me want to read the book of job
but i know what's going to happen i'll
start to read it and then it'll be
and then god said it unto you with the
yahweh and the the
seventh son of the [ __ ] hebedee
hobbity who and it's just like all right
you know
why don't they give it i'm sure there is
i'm sure there's an updated version of
it
will they actually write it in a more um
modern english like the band all right
bill
wife left bill so i got a text from my
wife a couple weeks ago
saying she had taken her dog and her
things
left and were getting a divorce wow
she gave you a text message you know
that's kind of the way to do it
in a selfish way you know
do you know i know somebody who did that
i knew somebody who was in a [ __ ]
relationship forever
and i guess they just didn't know how to
get out of it
so here's an option for people out there
men and women
and sir this has nothing to do with you
this just reminded me of this
so this [ __ ] guy his uh
his woman went on a cruise or went on
some sort of wine tasting thing
or whatever and
he i guess he knew that she was going on
this trip
so before she left
he already found another apartment
signed a lease and all that type
of [ __ ] so she leaves
i mean she was leaving for like two
three days
he had another buddy of mine went over
there
they packed up all his [ __ ] and [ __ ]
moved it out to this new place
and then you know he just lived in that
place
until the day she was coming back he
came back to the apartment
she comes home and immediately sees half
the [ __ ] is gone
and he just dropped the bomb like that
and said listen
you know we need to talk i'm not [ __ ]
happy
and when i tell you this [ __ ] woman
flipped the [ __ ] out flipped
the [ __ ] out like went absolutely
[ __ ] ballistic and
and i i always wanted to ask her why
what was it that made you flip out would
you would you have flipped out less
because she she didn't even go into the
the surprise of what
oh my god crying and went immediately to
anger
and i think it was because he was
already
out and
there wasn't going to be any sort of
closure
slash i can torture you and be a total
[ __ ] to you like he sidestepped all of
that
and just made this clean ass
[ __ ] break you know
dennis miller that's the news and i am
out of here
that's what i thought when he did it and
i don't know why i always smile when i
think because that's the thing you know
if you're gonna break up a woman you
just know
i mean i mean i never had to break up a
girl i was living with i can't imagine
that [ __ ]
hell and this person i mean that that's
one way to do it
um so if you are stuck in a relationship
and you don't know how to [ __ ] bring
it up
you just don't know how to do it that's
one way to do it because when they come
home and you're sitting there but
all your [ __ ] isn't there uh that's
that's
the conversation has begun
[ __ ] anyways
so getting back to this poor bastard he
goes her rationale
was that she always hated me oh my god
forget the eight instances of cheating
three post-marriages
that i three post-marriage that i
tolerated
just because is as good of a reason for
her
to leave as any wait a minute back up
here
wait a minute dude she cheated on you
eight [ __ ] times
five times before you got married i mean
dude what
come on man you didn't see this coming
all right i'm gonna save judgment here
uh he said forget about the eight
inch instances of cheating three post
marriages that i tolerated
uh then he writes in quote just because
is as good of reason for her to leave as
any
um here's where you pummel me
but she was my mom's but she was at my
mom's bedside with my mom
and i when my mom died okay
i didn't realize
dude you didn't write this well i didn't
realize to her
that nothing
i didn't realize to her that was nothing
but
her way in
i didn't realize that to her i i don't i
don't know he's
what that she went to that that that was
her way into your life
in my grief i didn't notice she went
full
andy dufresne just chipping away at my
sense of self
so she would [ __ ] around
so when she would [ __ ] around i thought
well no person in the world will hang on
to me
so this is better than being alone [ __ ]
it i'll do come on man
she and i have been together for nine
years married three my problem is that
as a 26 year old birthday was yesterday
none of my friends can relate and my
thousand yard stare okay relate
and my thousand-yard stare at the bar
just seems to be harsh
seems to harsh their hipster pbr buzz
dude this is the most difficult [ __ ]
thing i've ever tried to read
um dude you're only 26 years old get the
[ __ ] out of this thing go to the gym
is that your problem huh
you got a little doe around the [ __ ]
middle
that's it dude read up on nutrition gets
get some [ __ ] self-esteem man
this is ridiculous this [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know why she hated you
she's probably one of the reasons she
hates you because you're not sticking up
for yourself
this [ __ ] oh dude i i
you know what i'm not going to yell
you've already been through the [ __ ]
ring with this one i'm sorry you ran
into something like this
i'm sorry i don't know who the [ __ ] your
your male role model was when you were
growing up didn't build you up more but
they obviously didn't [ __ ] raise you
right and now you got to do it
okay you got to build yourself up man
you can't [ __ ]
you can't [ __ ] have something like
this going on you're like william h
macy and [ __ ] uh boogie nights
you can eventually [ __ ] shoot her in
the driveway [ __ ] your friend and
then go blow your own brains out you
don't want to be that guy
[ __ ] this woman because i've tried to
get back out there with some people i
know
but when they tried when they tell their
stories from college all i think is i
wonder if
john mccain gets this mad when people
his age
tell stories about woodstock
all right now where do we make the leap
there what their [ __ ] stories
and you're pissed because you missed out
on that
uh i must i'm optimistic
as for the most part my life is much
better
my friends think i'm exaggerating
because they saw us together
and my response is that people saw
elizabeth smart out in public too
and she wasn't and she wasn't fine
either
what the hell do i do the last time i
was single texting didn't exist
i couldn't drink legally i've lived with
my parents i looked at my parents
uh you got the point three examples ago
but i keep typing
i thought maybe as a comic when you
started going on the road and didn't
know people everywhere
it may have been a similar vibe yeah
dude like you're
you're starting from ground zero you're
totally beat down
you're 26 years old talking about like
you're 50.
you know you're fine
all right oh wait so you went there for
[ __ ] what did you say eight or nine
years let's do the math here
i text my wife
eight instances also you were there for
nine years
so you got together with this girl when
you were 17. she was still you were a
baby
all right i get it i get it and you
stayed with this girl and you never
cheated on her she cheated on you
and all those years of college when you
should have got your game together how
to talk to women but blah blah blah blah
yeah dude that's you you can you can
make up ground real quickly here you're
only 26 years old
um you just gotta
you just gotta get yourself out there
now i mean i wouldn't suggest just going
out to bars
look if you wanna [ __ ] a woman go out to
a bar do that if you wanna meet somebody
nice then i
i would i would be i would definitely
look elsewhere
uh do you have any hobbies do you like
sports
i would join some sort of uh [ __ ]
i don't know what the [ __ ] is the word
what's the word when they let
guys and women play together you know i
joined some [ __ ] like that
take a [ __ ] cooking class just
something
you know something where the where the
good girls go to
you know but you know if you just want
to go out and get laid
who gives a [ __ ] you what you got to do
is you got to get over being getting
rejected just go out to a bar
just talk some [ __ ] you know
don't go out and get plastered and use
that as your [ __ ] courage just go out
there and just talk some [ __ ]
you know and just go out there and just
say all right i'm gonna i'm gonna say
what's up to 10 different women tonight
all right or if that's too overwhelming
make it five or four
all right no no less than four all right
all right with no no pressure on the
results
just go out there and just [ __ ]
strike up a conversation
see how long you can keep it going and
and just you know whatever you're going
to be nervous
you're going to give a [ __ ] but with
each one you're going to give a [ __ ]
less
and the less you give a [ __ ] the more
relaxed you're gonna be
the funnier you're gonna be the more
you're gonna attract them it's it's
literally when you give a [ __ ]
when you give a [ __ ] you're scaring them
away when you care
you know you'll be fine all right but
it's you gotta grow up and stop
embracing this [ __ ] uh
this depressive [ __ ] because it's also
gonna make you an angry [ __ ]
and you're gonna [ __ ] hate women and
you're gonna push your friends away and
you end up being alone
all right unfortunately you [ __ ]
you wasted nine years of your life with
some [ __ ]
and you got [ __ ] married okay but it
wasn't a waste because now you know what
you don't want
all right so that's it but for the love
of god
do not get into another goddamn
relationship you got to make a pact with
yourself you're not going to go
from a nine year one three-year marriage
to [ __ ] jumping into something else
you got to stay
single and figure out what the [ __ ] you
want you might not want you might want
to like not even go out to [ __ ] bars
for a while
you know just go to the gym hit it like
a [ __ ] madman
you know and [ __ ] figure out what you
what you're looking for and then where
it should be and then go in that
direction
do that all right not everybody's gonna
be the guy who goes out and bangs a
[ __ ] hundred women who gives a [ __ ]
all right at the end of it if you find
[ __ ] love and you find the person
you're supposed to be with you won
okay so uh whatever
there's my [ __ ] two cents did i say
the f word enough
um all right from [ __ ] croatia
which is in [ __ ] europe look at this
guy breaking my balls from the other
side of the planet
all right i'll get right to it recently
my luck with the ladies change for the
better good for you sir i realized how
different men
are from women and started using that to
my advantage
well sir the last person please listen
to this guy
i'm 23 and in college i started college
three years
older so i am in class with 19 to 20
year olds
pretty much they are all ladies
not a single one of them is is annoying
i get along with all of them
but there is this one christina who acts
like
she's the only one with problems okay
well there's always gonna be a bad one
in there
uh we talked a couple of times even went
out on a date
she seemed interested but very distant
uh the date was very
tense unlike all the other dates
i can handle oh jesus you guys really
killed me this week
unlike all the other dates i can handle
somewhat manly
at least i act cool so everything goes
relatively smoothly i'm going to cut you
some slack sir because this is a [ __ ]
second language this is amazing
um this date was as as stiff as jay leno
i hated it uh so we didn't talk for a
couple of days after the horror date
uh my dad my bad for not knowing not
talking to her i know
no it isn't he had a bad date don't call
her back
you didn't have a good time why would
you pursue it uh
anyways then we started talking again
and some vibes are going
on but we only saw each other in class
then we started talking
some deep [ __ ] over facebook as 20 year
olds do
and i realize we don't get each other we
just don't understand one another all
right so walk away
she has a little circle of friends and a
lot of guys come on to her
but she's like very into herself and
[ __ ]
okay i know her self-centered feelings
are natural or her age but i am a little
bit older
but she's like no no one understands me
she's really a baby yeah dude you have
this all figured out
he goes we don't understand each other
at all it's like
we mean the same thing but awkwardly
argue over
the choice of the words we use man i
really want to bang her
she's i was gonna say she has to be
beautiful he said she's smoking hot
in the meantime i am all over the other
ladies
uh but i'm really restless about this
one i like her
but she will break me if i get
too much into her now look how he
started speaking like ivan drago
um so the gist of my [ __ ] ass letter
is how do i bang her now after the
shitty date and awkward facebook
arguments
uh goddamn i just realized she's cutting
my balls off when i talk to her
i must get my [ __ ] together if i want to
[ __ ] her but i still don't really know
how to do it [ __ ] okay uh
all right what are we gonna do um
all right how the [ __ ] did we undo what
the [ __ ] was already done
what would i do uh i would [ __ ]
you know what i would do i would just
charm the [ __ ] out of her and cl i would
come in
in a [ __ ] great mood even if you're
not in a great mood just come into class
you know this is i'm giving you the
[ __ ]
demon speech from uh fast time at
richmond high
you know you just come walking in like
your [ __ ] life is great
you know and she's gonna be like oh my
god he's
like i'm not like talking to him and
he's like having a good time does that
like mean i'm not pretty anymore like
that'll [ __ ] with her
[ __ ] the world revolves around me
that you can actually
now that you've been sucked into her
world you can still actually have a
great [ __ ] day
without needing her [ __ ] uh
attention or anything yeah just walk in
there like your life's the [ __ ]
and when you see her be really friendly
hey how are you give her a nice big hug
and then be [ __ ] flirting with all
the other [ __ ] women
that'll make her [ __ ] jealous i mean
he's basically gonna have to play a
[ __ ] game with a [ __ ] [ __ ] like
this
uh which is really a lot of work um
and it sounds like you you like you
sound like you're kind of the male
version of her
you know she kind of didn't let you
[ __ ] hit it so now you're kind of
getting wrapped up in this [ __ ] [ __ ]
that you don't even want
other your ego wants it you want to
[ __ ] bang her you know what you
should do sir is just [ __ ] walk away
that's what you do walk away and go bang
something else and when she actually
[ __ ] comes out you'd be like why
don't you call me anymore and just be
like
there's no vibe between us there really
isn't
you know you're beautiful but the
conversation is too awkward and i find
that you're just
really self-centered you're really into
yourself
and uh i find it annoying you know if
you tell it that you're probably going
to be closer to that [ __ ] [ __ ] than
you are
going the other way why don't you call
me oh sorry i've been busy
you just act like a [ __ ] loser don't
do that all right
you get this one by walking away from
this one that's that's that's my gut
feeling
all right sir you know what you do you
just walk in class you take your dick
out you put it right on a [ __ ] desk
and just go
you know really can we just stop already
and then when the teacher is like excuse
me
[ __ ] uh czechoslovakian name whatever
the [ __ ] your name is
all right sick i used to play for the uh
for the lakers who's [ __ ] over there
uh christ i'm sorry guys this podcast
stunk
just take your dick out and shake it in
her face listen i want to show you
something you could have had right
[ __ ] yeah right
how about you do that there can i tap
out on that
um this has been the monday morning
podcast everybody there you go
that's the podcast for this week go [ __ ]
yourselves next week i will feel better
and uh i hope i will be funnier okay
oh next week where the [ __ ] will i be
no i'll still be here i will still be
here and it'll be right before my whole
dirty south [ __ ] tour so i'll be
hyping that next week
all right that's it oh by the way i also
did an episode of uh greg fitzsimmons
podcast if you want to listen to that
one
uh yeah that's great listen to greg's
then listen to rogan's you're listening
to me gradually get sick
and this is the [ __ ] fallout of it
all right go [ __ ] yourselves i'll talk
to you next week
you